I work with developers who build apps on
Google Cloud but I often tell them to
use Firebase features I've heard the
same many of the developers I work with
use both Google cloud and Firebase in
their projects so let's have a look at
what Firebase features they can use to
supercharge their Google Cloud
[Music]
apps I'm Martin and I'm a developer
Advocate I've had various jobs within
Google over the last 17 years but now I
help developers build great apps on
Google Cloud I'm puff or Frank and I'm a
Firebase engineer I've been using
Firebase since the first beta version in
2012 I help developers build amazing
apps with Firebase and while we have
different titles Firebase and Google
Cloud are two sides of the same coin
right oh yes they are any Firebase
projects is really just a Google Cloud
project with some extra annotations so
if you have a Firebase project today you
already have a Google Cloud project so
it makes sense that men developers who
host their apps on Google Cloud use some
Firebase features yeah but what Firebase
features well I often see developers
using these three Firebase features with
their apps hosted on Google Cloud static
file hosting custom domains and user
authentication all right Martin let's go
through your list number one is static
file hosting now what is that developers
often need to serve static files like
HTML Pages JavaScript bundles or css
stylesheets and images all right so
those are the files that we just send to
the client right we don't run any code
on the server that's in them and you can
do that with Google Cloud without
Firebase right yes you can I work mostly
with serverless developers and they
often serve their static files from a
Google Cloud Storage bucket or they
include their static files in a
container that they deploy to Cloud run
in both cases they then add a load
balancer in front so their custom domain
can be used to read those files but
Firebase hosting can also serve static
files exactly puff I've seen many
developers run their service side code
on Google of cloud but use Firebase
hosting to serve static files to users
yeah Firebase hosting comes with some
useful features for that it only takes a
single command to deploy files to
Firebase Firebase hosting includes a
so-called content delivery Network or
CDN so that your users can get those
static files very quickly there's also
no fixed monthly cost for making the
files accessible from your own custom
domain I use Firebase hosting for some
of my production apps uh just for these
reasons very good now next on your list
there was custom domain what do you mean
by that well uh Cloud run is an
excellent way of running serers side
code without having to maintain servers
it Autos scales up and down with traffic
so it's easy to manage your code runs
when a URL is accessed but that
autogenerated URL contains hashes I've
seen those and I guess that's fine for
API not visible to people but you
wouldn't want to show a URL like that to
your actual users yeah that's right uh
if you need a perable URL you can add a
load balancer in front of your Cloud
round service sure you know you could
use Firebase hosting you know that with
Firebase hosting you don't have the
extra cost and complexity of a load
balancer that's right and it's easy to
set up just go to your Cloud run service
click
Integrations click add
integration and pick integration with
fireb hosting and that gives you the
default setup where all traffic to your
domain gets forwarded to your Cloud run
service that's great if your Cloud run
service can send static files to your
users but you can also use the Firebase
tools to create a more custom setup what
might be a good example well let's say
that you host a web app and if your
users access your domain.com they should
get the static HTML and JavaScript for
the homepage but then your JavaScript in
their browser can call yourdomain.com
Api to access your server side API that
you built in Cloud run this way the
static Files come from Firebase hosting
and the server side code still executes
in Cloud run so you get the best of both
worlds exactly all right that was the
second item on your list Martin the
third item is user authentication tell
me a bit more about that oh security is
hard it takes a lot of time to implement
yourself and if you do you might create
security holes oh yeah Firebase
authentication makes it easy to add user
login to your web or mobile agreed I've
talked with many developers who host
their apps on Google cloud and who use
Firebase for authentication they either
design their own login user interface
that calls Firebase authentication or
they import Firebase UI which provides
that login interface and then your
application will get the ID of the
current user but you won't have to store
passwords or to write a code to
integrate with login providers like
Google or Facebook you can also let your
users just enter their email address and
set their own password Firebase
authentication takes care of all of it
I've also seen uh some developers use
Google identity platform oh yeah that
just works like Firebase authentication
but it gives you some extra Enterprise
features like multiactor authentication
and MTI tennessy well I run a few
production applications that use
Firebase Authentication and puff do you
know what my favorite feature is no
what's that Martin when users forget
their passwords they don't email me
about it they can reset their own
passwords that makes my life so much
easier oh I can totally see that I
remember when we first started working
on Firebase UI and making the UI designs
there are so many screens and so many
flows that I never thought of and now
you don't have to think of them either I
love that all right we covered a lot of
ground so let's recap every Firebase
project is a Google Cloud project
Firebase and Google Cloud are two sides
of the same coin they work well together
Martin you work with developers who host
their apps Google Cloud what Firebase
features do you see them use the most
often well they host their static files
on Firebase hosting it's simple has no
fixed cost and it includes a CDN for
better
performance two they Point their custom
domain name to their Cloud run service
using Firebase hosting and finally they
authenticate users with Firebase
authentication it's less work and safer
than writing something yourself and you
don't have to respond to emails from
your users who forgot their passwords
anymore right yes that's right puff
thank you for joining me today thanks
for having me Martin this was fun and
thank you everyone for watching if you
have any questions for puff or me please
write a comment below also let me know
if there are any other less topics you'd
like to see in future episodes until
next
[Music]
time